hello everyone it's my great pleasure to
introduce marina Picciotto she is the
Charles BG Murphy professor of
psychiatry and also in the department's
of neuroscience and pharmacology at Yale
University after receiving her
bachelor's from Stanford and doing her
PhD at Rockefeller she did a postdoc at
the Pasteur Institute and today you'll
have the opportunity to hear about her
outstanding and very influential work on
largely on nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors and how they can be involved
in psychiatric disease she's published
over 220 papers and for her work she's
received a number of awards I'll just
name a few including the nurse add an
independent investigator as well as the
senior investigator award the very
prestigious will let's key Award for
innovative research in drug addiction
and alcoholism and she has been elected
to be a triple AAS fellow and also the
National Academy of Medicine perhaps
equally important or impressive about
Marina is her incredible service she
serves on a number of advisory board
steering committees and award selection
committees and is now the chief editor
of the Journal of Neuroscience and as a
mentor Marina is truly inspirational
she's a mentor to mentors and a role
model to all she's incredibly generous
not only to her own trainees but I find
to all young scientists in the next
generation I remember my very first sfn
where I presented a poster on Wednesday
morning where Marina was the only person
to attend and I found that incredibly
inspiring to this day and I'm sure she's
impacted many of your careers as well so
please join me in giving Marina a very
warm welcome
[Applause]
that may be one of my proudest
achievements to be one of the poster
attendees on the last morning of sfn
thank you that's really cool so um we
work on a lot of different behavioral
constructs and the ones I'm going to
talk about today are related to anxiety
and depression and I'm going to show
data that we have that is perhaps
largely pharmacological but really tries
to go back and forth from humans to
rodents in a way that perhaps is
tractable to really do translational
work from basic neuroscience to human
psychiatric illness and back again
so I'm gonna show you the first slide
which is one that perhaps every one of
you has in your slide deck and it's one
that I'm aiming at Steve Hyman because
he's actually written on this and the
question is how do we actually model
depression or anxiety in a rodent and
every one of you has seen this slide
because of course an anxious rodent a
depressed rodent and a happy rodent all
looks the same and the answer that I
have to that question is that you start
with a human right so all of the things
that I'm going to talk about today
actually began with manipulations in
human patients so in the 1970s going
into the early 80s Janowski and his
colleagues actually did a number of
pharmacological experiments and humans
both first with depressed people with a
history of depression and then in people
with absolutely no history of
psychiatric illness where they gave
people a cholinesterase active inhibitor
so astal cholinesterase is the primary
breakdown enzyme for astal choline so
what they were doing was increasing the
lifetime of Astle choline and the human
brain and body acutely one time and they
asked these patients how do you feel and
across a number of studies which were
published in a series of papers what
janeski and his colleagues were able to
do was induce symptoms of anxiety and
depression acutely in human subjects
whether or not they had a history and
what does that suggest it suggests it in
some way during active behavior in
humans if you increase the amount of
time that Estel choline stays in this
in a synapse we don't know where that
you can induce something that humans
endorse as anxiety and depression so
where is this this Estill choline being
used where is it signaling well of
course we all know that the primary
neurotransmitter in the autonomic
ganglia is Astle choline it could very
simply be that people had more signaling
at in the sympathetic nervous system
therefore felt heart rate increases felt
symptoms of anxiety although that
doesn't really explain the symptoms of
depression we know that throughout the
brain actually I can actually I can pace
if I feel like it and it put down my
pointer somewhere did I put it all right
I can't paste because I lost my pointer
ah no that's not it that's oh this is it
that's the advance er I think I have
strewn the various paraphernalia of
speaking across the entire alright so
this will be my IQ test because if it is
a laser pointer
I will now mistake it for the slide
advancer and I apologize in advance
alright so yes we have a still choline
signaling it's essential for sympathetic
tone it's essential for sympathetic
signaling but we also know that there
are cholinergic cell bodies in number of
brain areas and in fact in increasing
numbers of brain areas as we do single
cell sequencing throughout the brain but
primarily there's a number of
cholinergic brainstem nuclei that are
absolutely essential for arousal and
then the basal forebrain complex that
are these these neurons are projecting
extremely widely throughout the brain
and they're innervating pretty much all
of cortex the the thalamus the
hippocampus and amygdala and in general
these neurons are neuromodulator not
neuromodulatory they are however
activated by stressful stimuli and this
is another old paper this is in this
case from rat and this is a study using
micro dialysis where asked extracellular
acyl choline is sampled in the
hippocampus dorsal hippocampus in
particular
after a physical stressor so in this
paper by the shores group the micro
dialysis probe is implanted and then the
animals restrained and what you can see
is that astral colon and the dorsal
hippocampus goes out up as the restraint
stress continues it because of sampling
problems it's likely that this Estill
choline is actually going up concomitant
with the beginning of the stress and
ending probably somewhere around the end
of the stress and staying high as long
as that physical stressor is around this
is one brain area where we know that
stressful environmental conditions are
not just activating the autonomic
ganglia but also central nuclei that are
important for enervating broad swaths of
the cortex so if this is the case then
an increasing ACH signaling may be a
model of maladaptive stress response and
the question is can we take that
observation in humans with the
cholinesterase antagonist replicated in
mice and start to use that perhaps as a
model of what acute Astle choline
signaling might be doing in an actively
depressed human and start to take apart
where this is happening in the brain or
if it's happening in the brain so that's
where we're going to start so we had a
number of of experiments that went into
looking at the cholinergic system and
trying to evaluate where we might look
but first we simply replicated
janowski's experiment give the same
cholinesterase tech antagonist
peripherally physostigmine and we asked
can we use first of all biochemical
measures to see if we're really
decreasing breakdown of acetylcholine we
can in fact use biochemical assays a
vestal cholinesterase activity show that
we can reduce it centrally and we can
use these much-maligned batteries of
stress induced behaviors to see if
there's a change in the activity of
these animals so first of all we used in
this case tail suspension easiest
experiment you can do in a mouse you
suspend in that animal by its tail the
adaptive response should be probably to
continue to try to write itself if you
give an acute in a injection of an
antidepressant that works in humans the
animal will try to write itself for
longer if you increase
stress then the animal will give up
sooner so immobility is a sign of giving
up and when we give this physostigmine
peripherally these animals actually give
up more and this goes along with the
ability of the fuzzy stigma to reduce
Estel cholinesterase activity all right
so that's where we're starting
we know that Astle choline is mediated
through two broad families of receptors
muscarinic anta receptors which are
metabotropic g-protein coupled receptors
nicotinic receptors which are pentameric
ion channel containing receptors they're
the ones that we tend to focus on but we
know also that these receptors have to
be the transducers of whatever estill
choline signaling is induced by this dis
pharmacological challenge so the first
question is can we block these acute
effects of asheville choline in these
models of stress-related behavior with
pharmacological means and the answer is
yes if we give either a nicotinic
antagonist or a muscarinic antagonist
along with the Estel cholinesterase
blocker then we reduce not only the
ability of the cholinesterase to induce
this immobility we have this em--to
depressant like response it looks a lot
like antidepressant response as we've
seen with other pharmacological
challenges if we put them together it's
a little bit better but we may have
actually maxed out at with one or the
other which means that probably a still
choline is selecting it is acting it
needs all of its receptors if you take
out one of their family these families
of receptors we don't get this
stress-related behavior all right that's
not really very surprising if you
increased estill choline hopefully you
can reverse its effects by blocking its
receptors more important if we're
actually going to call this in some ways
a similar response to what we see in
humans we should take a completely
unrelated compound one that works in
humans is an antidepressant and see if
it reverses the effects of this
cholinergic change so we took fluoxetine
prozac and what we see is that prozac
actually reverses the physostigmine
effects very potently so here's the
immobility that's increased when we
cholinesterase activity it's reversed
back to baseline by fluoxetine
administration and what this suggests is
that this is not
simply a reflection of system-level
activity that is completely unrelated to
the kinds of behaviors that might be
important for anxiety and depression but
in fact generalizes across systems that
are involved in human depression so okay
here we have our pharmacological model
let's now go in use what we can in
animals to find out where this is
happening this is still peripheral
administration it could still be
happening in the sympathetic ganglia
we're actually in the brain is it in the
brain so again here's where we started
Estel choline has actually been
evaluated in many different brain areas
there are some brain areas where it
changes but really not very much
amygdala for example you can see that
restraint stress increases estill coin
signaling it's very very high at
baseline I will come back to that it
doesn't go a whole lot err with a
physical stressor the most inducible
area that's been seen reproducibly is
hippocampus so we decided to start there
and what we did was first to use to
develop an [ __ ] cholinesterase
knockdown strategy we used a v2 now
adeno-associated virus --is are very
heterogeneous a v2 is useful because it
infects cell bodies so if you put
something into an a a v2 and you put it
in the brain you know it's going to be
in the cells with cell bodies in the
brain area that you infused okay and we
did a nice rescue experiment where not
only did we put a small hairpin RNA that
is target that targets the mouse ACA Chi
we also designed a cDNA with the human
astal cholinesterase so that we could at
the same time that we are knocking down
the mouse copy if we wanted to replace
it with the human copy that was not
sensitive to this small hairpin RNA okay
so we have a control and you can see
here is that when we knock down the
shrna we lose this dark staining which
is actually again a biochemical measure
of a spelled cholinesterase biochemistry
of activity of the enzyme you can see
that for whatever reason this AV to
really just likes the hippocampus when
we put it in we don't have very much for
sub regions of the hippocampus it seems
to fill
the whole structure there's probably a
plus and a minus but what you can also
see is that when we knock down a stile
cholinesterase in the hippocampus more
broadly when we look at exploratory
behavior which is simply whether the
mouse is going to go someplace scary or
not that knocking down the
cholinesterase locally in hippocampus is
sufficient to recapitulate blocking
cholinesterase activity in the whole
body there you see that how much a
normal mass will explore a light
compartment of an plus maze that goes
way down when we knock down color s
cholinesterase an increased local muscle
choline signaling and hippocampus same
is true in another model like dark box
all of these are simply where does the
animal choose to explore that's where we
started now I can show you a number of
these other stress induced behaviors and
that is all of these models that are
sensitive to antidepressants that work
in human of them tail suspension and for
swim are the same immobility tests that
I told you about but one of them has a
little bit more face validity because
it's sensitive not to an acute
administration of classical
antidepressants but is only sensitive to
chronic administration so let me work
walk you through this a little bit what
you can see here is that if we put shrna
and we increase cholinesterase activity
only in the hippocampus we get more
mobility across these two models it's
good when we work on mouse models
there's a lot of there's a million
reasons that you can change the activity
of mouse change the behavior of a mouse
and if the behavior changes in the same
way across these models a little bit
more confidence that you're measuring
what you think you are and what you can
see here is that if we just use the
control the scrambled shrna there's
absolutely no effect and if we use the
shrna plus the human replacement of the
shrna so this is a control on selective
effects of Dicer any off-target effects
we completely rescue the ability of the
shRNA to both increase this immobility
and also in fact to change the activity
of cholinesterase in fact we get quite a
lot more cholinesterase active
when we replaced with the human form
okay that's true across these two models
and the mobility but here is something
where we were actually a little bit more
interested so social defeat stress is
something where and I talked about this
with K it's not a super great model for
depression because it's really an
adaptive response what happens is do you
take a normal happy social Mouse who
likes to explore other mice and you
expose it to a big bully mouse of
another strain and the big bully Mouse
beats it up for a little bit you
separate them and you expose the two
mice to each other for long enough that
the very sweet social Mouse now no
longer wants to have any other mice so
on the training days and you can do it
for three days you can do it for seven
days you get exposure and learning that
there's a bully Mouse around you get the
stress response mounting and then on the
test day you expose this Mouse to a
brand new conspecific and you ask does
the mouse choose to go and explore the
new Mouse or is it going to avoid the
area where there's a mouse so if we if
we do this for seven days what you can
see is that on the test day a normal
Mouse exposed to seven days of de-feet
stress will interact less with a mouse
this is actually not surprising this is
a mouse that has learned that us can
actually do it harm but we did a
sub-threshold social defeat we only
expose the mouse for three days to the
scary bully mouse and in that case it
actually is a sub-optimal social defeat
stress that's the exploratory behavior
of a non-stress Mouse and this is the
exploratory behavior of an animal that
has had the astal cholinesterase
knockdown in the hippocampus only
exposed to this sub threshold level of
social defeat and here's the controls
again if we use the scrambled shrna
nothing happens and if we rescue the
shrna with human cDNA we also don't have
an effect of this cholinesterase change
so what that suggests to me
is that increasing cholinergic signaling
locally in the hippocampus is sufficient
to mimic the effect of the systemic
blockade that we saw worked in humans
works in mice and at that point we can
ask do changes in cholinergic signaling
actually happen when people are acutely
depressed so we know that we can
artificially increase cholinergic
signaling or we can't Janowski can but
is this reflective of anything that's
actually happening in human depressed
patients so we're very in that we took
part with our colleagues in developing a
nicotinic acetylcholine receptor tracer
that works in humans we first used it
for SPECT imaging now it's being used
for PET imaging it can be used in awake
behaving animals but it can also be used
in a wake behaving humans and the way
that it works is that here is actually a
diagram of the channel that is the
nicotinic acetylcholine receptor the in
this case SPECT tracer binds it exactly
the same spot as either nicotine or
Astle choline at the interface between
subunits of these nicotinic receptors we
can infuse it into the brains of people
who are non-smokers people who are
smokers have very efficient competition
by nicotine of this binding site so you
don't really see any any binding but if
we infuse this into the brain of
non-smokers who are either not depressed
or actively depressed we can look at
occupancy of this site alright and this
is one this is a control nonsmoker what
you can see is so here's the brain
that's the sort of the nose part this is
a side view nose again this hot spot
that's the thalamus thalamus is loaded
with high affinity nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors this tracer
shows them just the same way they would
in a mouse brain slice human is a very
good model for mouse and what you can
see is here is an acutely depressed
nonsmoker what you can see quite clearly
is that in this heat map there is less
binding of this tracer so when my
colleagues first saw these images they
said hey marina very cool people who are
actively depressed have fewer Nestle
choline receptors now there are a few
problems with that
one is that the only human disorder I
know of that actually gets rid of
nicotinic acetylcholine receptors is
neuro degeneration neurons hold on to
these receptors unless they're dead so
it seemed unlikely to me that an acutely
depressed individual would have doctors
but it it was possible the other problem
with that is of course that this is a
competitive tracer so what does that
mean it means that if there's some level
of Astle choline circulating in the
extracellular space that's going to
occupy some interfaces of the nicotinic
acid Aucoin receptor if it's low enough
they're still going to be interfaces
that are available for the labeled
tracer to bind if instead there's more
austell choline signaling in the brain
of someone who's acutely depressed
they're going to be more interfaces
occupied by the endogenous Astle choline
and now when we add the trace that are
going to be fewer spaces for this to
bind so we could test that so here's the
data from the SPECT this is actually
also very interesting and was very
surprising to us what we saw was at any
brain area that was examined there was
less binding of this competitive tracer
to the nicotinic acetylcholine receptors
so that suggested to me this was not
hyperactivity of one pathway but
something more brought about either the
metabolism of estill choline or in some
way the biogenesis of a stole choline
that was not independent on activity of
a single pathway the other thing that
you can see is that this was seen in
many different cortical areas but was
also seen midbrain and brain stem
structures so again not a single set of
neurons which was very surprising to me
the other thing you don't see on here be
just for confusion sake is that although
this is people who have never been
depressed and this is people who are
acutely depressed at the time of imaging
people who had a history of depression
but were current it right in between
kind of cool alright so we as
neuroscientists could actually help our
clinical colleagues by asking for
post-mortem tissue from the brain Bank
Douglas Brain Bank in Canada where we
were able to get control
brain tissue mostly from people who
sit-ins and so on age matched and sex
matched non-smokers who were died while
actively depressed mostly from suicide
and then age matched and sex matched
schizophrenic brains as a sort of a
psychiatric control and what we were
able to do is then washout astal choline
because you take little slices of brain
tissue
we took the anterior cingulate because
it was one of the brain areas that had
been sampled in the SPECT imaging and we
asked if you wash out all the astral
choline is there a difference in number
or affinity of the receptors that bind
to this tracer the answer is absolutely
not so in gray matter and white matter
there was no difference in nicotinic
receptor number and I can tell you also
affinity so whatever's happening here it
is not due to loss of nicotinic
receptors so then we asked we
collaborated with irene esther lists and
other of our clinical colleagues to ask
if we could recapitulate the Janowski
study let's treat these a bunch of
normal control with the same
cholinesterase antagonist with
physostigmine and ask if first of all do
we recapitulate ah see I found the IQ
test can we recapitulate this finding in
individuals who are challenged with
physostigmine and the answer is
absolutely yes this is five individuals
each of which is its own within subject
control and they're imaged before
physostigmine or after physostigmine and
all five of these individuals
physostigmine challenged recapitulated
what we saw in actively depressed
patients in addition we have replicated
this this is in unipolar depressed
patients so the first study that we did
this also happens in patients with
bipolar disorder when they are actively
depressed that suggests because bipolar
disorder and unipolar disorder do not
share an awful lot of genetics that this
is probably not really due to some crazy
cholinergic genetic defect people who
are who are depressed but potentially
something downstream of other defects
and that's really where i wanted to show
this to this audience in particular
because
when people have when people when I and
colleagues have looked for genes in
cholinergic biosynthesis chat : estrus
itself in the available genetic
databases there has not yet been a
demonstration that those genes are
linked to depression so it either
suggests that this is downstream of some
other pathway that is primary or that
this is in some way the consequence of
stress signaling is chronically changed
and I want to just tell you one piece of
information that I didn't add in here
this is kind of important in the
cholinesterase knockdown studies I
showed you that we did the control that
you could rescue the cholinesterase
phenotype by putting in the human scene
cDNA and I told you we did that one
injection at one time if instead of
rescuing at the same moment we go in six
weeks later and we put in the human cDNA
into the hippocampus of animals that
have had the shRNA we no longer rescue
so there is plasticity also downstream
of this out of control I will say it out
of control
cholinergic signaling that we see in the
depressed brain that we see in remitted
patients that does know it no longer
appears to be sensitive to manipulations
of a spell : s tres q of a spell
cholinesterase activity in the
hippocampus and that's something we're
really interested in alright so can we
now we've got this mouse model can we
use it to ask where in the brain is
cholinergic signaling really important
for these stress-related behaviors we
know that Ashville choline is really
released throughout the brain we've seen
even in the human that there's many many
brain areas implicate can start to go in
with tools that we have that we've
developed for many reasons to examine
the nicotinic receptors for example and
ask where is this happening so the first
thing I'm going to show you again is
pharmacological we've showed actually a
long time ago ten years ago now 11 years
ago that if we block Astle choline
receptors or if we decrease Astle
choline signaling
through these receptors using a partial
agonist so as you all know partial
agonist can actually activate its
receptor but so much less than the
normal endogenous ligand that in a sense
if there's high Astle choline signaling
a partial agonist would decrease
signaling we could give Mecca melamine
again antagonist or cytosine which is
this partial agonist to normal mice and
we can basically increase struggling as'
decrease in mobility in these tests of
stress-related behavior okay so we know
that and the it goes along with the idea
that if we can increase a stool choline
signaling only in the hippocampus we can
increase these stress-related behaviors
now if we decrease nicotinic signaling
even in the absence of a an acute
stressor I do think of mice is really
kind of chronically stressed they're a
little bit like assistant professors or
graduate students so I'm not sure that
we can call completely normal however if
you decrease a spell coin receptor
signaling only in mice that have not had
other interventions you can have this
antidepressant like effect
so does this share neurochemical mesh
measurement the neurochemical aspects
just I just as I was showing you that we
can use de teen to reverse the effects
of these cholinergic manipulations can
we now combine different agents and see
if we can get nicotinic and in this case
serotonergic agents to work in tandem so
here we have again a pharmacological
study here is this partial agonist if we
use a sub most of the partial agonist we
have no behavioural effect if we use
relatively low dose of fluoxetine
doesn't have much of an effect but if we
combine those two sub threshold doses
together we see not only a decrease in
this immobility test but we also see an
increase in association with a
conspecific in the social defeat test
these two together suggest that somehow
there's convergent signaling of target
of the under depressants that most
people are prescribed and this
cholinergic nicotinic M tag a partial
agonist so where is this happening we
know that 5-ht 1a receptors are at least
part
of the one of the targets of fluoxetine
serotonin that is signaling downstream
of fluoxetine and so we know that these
are expressed both in the serotonin
neurons themselves their Auto receptors
but also postsynaptically in the
hippocampus so what we've done is to use
the same strategy we made small hairpin
RNAs against the five ht1 Center we
infused them either into the dorsal
raphe or into the hippocampus again same
AAV - so we're only getting cell bodies
even though the projections from the
Rifai go to the hippocampus when we
knock down 5h t1a and the dorsal refe we
don't do anything to fight ht1 a except
on terminals in the hippocampus and what
you can see is that in the animals that
have the scrambled shrna both a v h t1 a
agonist that's 8 hydroxy dope deep at
decreases in mobility so does that
partial agonist of nicotinic receptors
and once you knock down the serotonin
receptor neither it is now effective and
really this speaks to where we are from
the 1970s where we thought of the brain
is a big bag of neurotransmitters where
serotonin really was the depression
transmitter or norepinephrine was
involved in mania obviously that's not
the case what we're thinking about in
general modulate neuromodulators that
are released widely throughout the brain
that are coordinating the activity of
circuits that are important for adaptive
behaviors and so as you look at each of
these neuromodulators that are released
in response to normal sensory stimuli in
the case of Astle choline we know
stressful alerting experiences that when
they actually signal together they
coordinate the activity of circuits in
this case probably originating in the
hippocampus that are important for
adaptive behaviors and as these signals
actually converge then you get
plasticity and over a longer time period
then you might get a bear and ethnicity
that will result in these changes
longer-term changes in behavior so we
know that the epic campus is one
critical site because we've actually
used a AV to
to change the expression of a couple of
different receptor subtypes and
molecules in the hippocampus but is this
also the place where this it is seen
this nicotinic agent or or actually
nicotinic receptor signaling is
occurring I'm just going to show you a
subset of data we've had a lot more but
this is just to show you that it's not
the whole story I'm going to show you an
incomplete response so here is one
subtype of the nicotinic receptor alpha
seven it's interesting because it's
implicated in some psychiatric illnesses
for example schizophrenia
it's a weird receptor because it's made
it's a home imir 5 alpha sevens together
make one receptor it's interesting
because it's very permeable to calcium
so it's thought to be important for
synaptic plasticity in for example the
amygdala which I'll talk about in minute
alpha 7 is essential in the pórtico
amygdala fibers for glutamate dependent
LTP so it's really been the target of a
lot of electrophysiological studies
around cholinergic signaling and
plasticity and what you can see is that
if we use an agonist a partial agonist
but an agonist nonetheless of alpha so
that we can actually get more time a
mobile sorry yes more time a mobile so
this is again in sort of the direction
of increasing Astle choline it's not
significant but an antagonist of this
receptor decreases in mobility so this
looks a little bit more like the
antidepressant like effect we get of
nicotinic blockade all right so now if
we look at a poor man's a biochemists
marker of activity in the hippocampus
generally this is going to be a marker
of principal neuron activity because
that's where the signal is strongest
what we see is that physostigmine so
again blocking Astle choline breakdown
increases activity in principal neurons
really pretty much throughout the
hippocampus and we can block that by
blocking alpha 7 scans sort of
consistent but then we get out of
consistency because when we start
knocking down alpha 7 locally we don't
really have very much of an effect in
the hippocampus we have an effect of
alpha 7 to decrease in mobility slightly
but it really
in anyway back to baseline here's the
increased by FISA Stig main and at
baseline we have no effect at all what I
showed you earlier is that if you block
nicotinic receptors more broadly we have
a profound effect already at baseline so
this is not the whole story
so what else might be happening so one
of the things that we know is from those
microdialysis studies and other studies
in terms of induce ability stress does
increase activity of Astle cooling or
levels of Astle choline in the
hippocampus but in particular the
cholinergic inputs to the amygdala are
very very high at baseline and they stay
high with stress and I don't know if any
of you have ever looked at a mouse brain
atlas but did you know that the counters
staying to look at the different brain
areas is actually I still cholinesterase
it is and if you look at the amygdala
the part of the amygdala really stands
out this is interest conversations I've
had earlier about other nuclei the
hotspot is a basal lateral amygdala and
in in vivo electrophysiology studies of
Astle choline neuron inputs to the basal
lateral amygdala they are extremely high
their their tonically firing at very
high rates at baseline they go up a
little bit with whole lot so here's an
area where activity is high and it stays
high so what happens if we block the
nicotinic receptors or we block we have
these pharmacological agents that have
behavioral consequences to see fuss in
other brain areas so this is again an
older paper and you can see is and just
here's the summary data if we use either
saline or these two nicotinic agents
that do different things the partial
agonist and the complete antagonist that
we get a similar behavioral response to
these two agents and the place that we
really only see a big similar change in
Cephas X basal lateral amygdala the
antagonists pretty good there's a
decrease in see fossa in a number of
brain areas this partial agonist which
again is behaviorally relevant only
really decreases activity here why is
that interesting again what's the
partial agonist do stimulates on its own
but if the in Dodge
neurotransmitter is very very it's going
to act to decrease the activity of that
normal neurotransmitter so that's
happening in the BL a so what happens if
we go into the amygdala and start to do
similar manipulations well here we can
put the pharmacological agents just into
the amygdala I'm not gonna say basal
lateral amygdala because we're good
we're not that good
basal lateral amygdala still pretty
small in a mouse but if we put into the
amygdala in here are the placements we
can actually decrease immobility in here
is the tail suspension test we've done
that battery we can also knock down
either the heteromeric or the beta or
the home Americ nicotinic receptors in
the basal lateral amygdala it can show
that we can decrease cephas expression
at baseline by either of those knock
downs that means again tonic signaling
through nicotinic receptors is occurring
in B LA and now if we look at behavior
there's something interesting that comes
out one is that across all of these
models here's the decrease in a mobility
from a in somewhat and not so much an
anxiety like behavior but decrease in
immobility and these two tasks increase
in exploration in the chronic social
defeat alpha 7 doesn't look the same I
think that this is doing something
different and I'll come back to this in
a second so there's some effect on this
exploration this anxiety related measure
much less on these models of immobility
and nothing in social defeat so this
home America one seems to be really
important for this battery of behavioral
tests I think this one reflects data
that's come out from Laura rolls lab
other labs this is the receptor that's
more important for plasticity we're
looking here acute of during a task so
short-term effects this is the
expression of behaviors that we see
again and again with acute manipulations
using behaviorally relevant
antidepressants but in tests that in
fact don't reflect the human consequence
of antidepressant use which only after
three to six weeks of administration so
I think this is what's downstream I
think Estel choline signaling is
downstream of the chronic administration
of some of these
antidepressant agents that are effective
in humans and that means that the
plasticity that might be occurring as a
result of alpha7 signaling may in fact
be part of the mechanisms of change in a
stole choline signaling overtime and
that's to be done okay so we've got
these different effects we can now
challenge with physostigmine we don't
get a complete reversal by these
amygdala manipulations which again go to
the idea that amygdala is one of the
nodes hippocampus is involved there are
probably other brain areas maybe also
prefrontal cortex we've looked there
it's a little more complicated but we
can start to put together under what
circumstances is the signaling high
under what circumstances is it inducible
and so this is our current rather
ridiculous biochemists cartoon of the
brain but we're now beginning to
interrogate some of the circuit level
questions that can be asked about what
Astle choline signaling is doing in each
of these brain areas so for example in
hippocampus we know that the large
majority of and actually an amygdala as
well a large majority of nicotinic Astle
cloning receptors are expressed on gaba
neurons we know that it's probably not
selective for one subclass but we have a
lot of different models already from
people who have been really bashing the
different nice GABAergic subtypes either
in a big dealer or hypocrite showing
that for example somatostatin positive
neurons VIP positive neurons and
parvalbumin Thank You P V positive
neurons have different roles in amygdala
the same is true in hippocampus I'm
really particularly interested in the
idea that some classes pick inter
neurons may be important not for
silencing all of their neighbors but
instead for silencing and coordinating
the firing of principal neurons so that
after the GABAergic activity decreases
but the principal neurons are
coordinated so that there's feed-forward
activity for a long period of time after
the GABAergic signaling is
and that's been shown by a really nice
group in Australia who silenced in
particular chandelier cells in the
amygdala and showed that what you got
was a very very long increase in
activity once those chandelier cells
were actually relieved of inhibition
transiently one of the ideas is that
nicotinic receptors on subclasses of
GABAergic inter neurons in each of these
structures could in fact dis inhibit one
possibility is that you have simply a
chain of inhibition so that activating
nicotinic receptors on one subpopulation
of neurons will dis inhibit principal
neurons by inhibiting another population
sorry for the Baroque explanation but we
can interrogate that and we are now
using cell type selective knockdown
coupled with dreads to either increase
or decrease Astle choline in the
hippocampus where we think that the
effect of decreasing Astle choline will
be minimal because we think that stress
will actually increase Astle choline and
here in the amygdala where we have seen
the effect of increasing estill choline
is minimal
whereas decreasing tone is in fact very
behaviorally relevant in in mice so the
question is is there a way to use the
cholinergic input to these two
structures to find out whether this is
something that is a trait is high
signaling we can do this using for
example the spectra pet tracer is high
signaling through estill choline in the
a risk factor for developing depression
or a risk factor for susceptibility to
stress or a consequence of stress and
does change there's a dynamic range of
estill choline signaling here in the
hippocampus actually give you more or
less resiliency too and the development
of either anxiety disorders or
depressive disorders and that's
something that I would love to be able
to work with clinicians to find out so I
am going to stop there because this is
my summary and I have a whole other
thing on aggression and I'd hate
two actually overstay my welcome but
just to go back to the idea that if you
start with a human I think the most
remarkable finding of some of these
studies is that there is a consistent
increase in Astle choline signaling
throughout the brain when people are
actively depressed and if they're
remitted there's still an increase above
completely unaffected individuals and
that suggests that it is an area that is
ripe for investigation in human subjects
we know that in general Hostel choline
is thought to focus attention so
beautiful studies from many labs
including Martin sardars have shown that
what Astle choline signaling does in the
principal neurons layer 5 decreases
noise and it increases get glutamate
signaling in response to a sensory input
so the timing is absolutely essential
when a relevant sensory input comes in
Astle choline signaling goes up and what
that does is increase basically the
center-surround kind of of activity in
sensory areas of cortex that you would
expect is essential for detecting
salient signals however in the amygdala
we know there is a couple of things that
go on so in fear conditioning if you
increase a still calling signaling
during encoding not much more fear
conditioning acutely but extinction
learning is slowed which is goes along
with a stole choline induced long-term
potentiation of cortical amygdala
glutamate signaling on two principal
neurons in the amygdala that plasticity
is in contrast to what we see
pharmacologically or with the knockdown
see an acute behavioral response during
the task and not learning to respond
over time I think there are multiple
things going on so we would suggest that
perhaps too much Estel choline does
focus your attention it does increase
your ability either acutely or
chronically to respond to negative
information and our sort of working
hypothesis is that specific for negative
information we've started to explore
this we've tried
look at what happens if you increase
casework other work has suggested that
oops that signaling in the MiG doula is
not only selected for negative
information we cannot change positive
valence information so far by increasing
Astle choline signaling in the amygdala
or decreasing or change in the nicotinic
receptor control that's very early
that's why I don't show you this these
data may change but the working
hypothesis is that in fact what Astle
choline is for is - yes your attention
toward those survival relevant negative
experiences including stress and
including dangerous aspects of your
environment and then finally as I've
shown you in the both the the contrast
between what's happening in the
hippocampus - what's happening in the
amygdala there are two sorts of
signaling both of which are important in
similar direction that is that the tonic
signaling for Astle choline in the
amygdala is also already essential in
unaffected animals to keep their level
of responding in these stress-related
paradigms high and at least in a mouse
if you decrease that Astle coin sigma
big delay you already have resilience
you already have more sort of struggle
against these stressful stimuli and in
contrast you this phasic signaling in
the hippocampus it's induced by relevant
information it's induced by stressful at
least in the mouse by either social
defeat stress or by a physical stressor
and at that point you have a dynamic to
respond in a relevant way to stressful
events in your environment so I'm going
to stop there and I will jump to the
acknowledgments so that you can let me
know if you have any questions and I
would like to particularly acknowledge
the folks in the lab who have done these
experiments and first of all Barbara
Calderon who's actually at Harvard
running excuse me a behavioral core was
the first person in the group who made
the observation that Astle choline
signaling in the mouse actually was
involved in mouse models of
stress-related behavior and she was the
one who on
covered the Janowski papers which I had
not seen and it's quite interesting why
most of us have not seen them and that
is that janeski you've probably seen
them and in fact psychiatrists know them
and find them amusing but what happened
was Janowski in an entire hypothesis
that Astle : was the depression
neurotransmitter norepinephrine was the
mania transmitter and therefore a
balance between astal choline and
norepinephrine would determine whether
you were in a depressed state or a manic
state and he made this hypothesis right
at the beginning of the prozac
revolution right as this came out really
the entire paradigm of how do how does
depression work was based on how to
serotonin reuptake inhibitors work and
the field went hmm and Astle choline has
really not been something that's been
widely studied there have been some
small clinical trials of for example
antimuscarinic drugs primarily by wayne
Dravet's they've all been quite small
and I would say underpowered looks like
if they were to hold up that it's
rapid-acting which is sort of in keeping
with the idea that these things are
occurring during the time that someone's
active actively depressed rather than
over time and there have been
unfortunately there's been a lot of
small studies of a nicotinic antagonist
and depressed people that that showed
some efficacy but one giant Astra Zeneca
trial failed so that's never going to go
anywhere which I'm sad about because I
do think that there are options for
better better and more selective
nicotinic agents that might be more
effective it's not going to happen
big failure alright so that was Barbara
Reba Rehman Stein was a graduate student
in my lab and first started using the
molecular genetic models the knockout
models which I didn't show to look at
which receptor subtypes might be
involved most of the data that I showed
you today in terms of the astal
cholinesterase project and the alpha 7
and amygdala a beta 2 knockdown were
done by young minora who's a longtime
research scientist in my group and these
are the other current laboratory think
collaborators like Zubin bagua gar who's
the
psychiatrist who did that first study
backed tracer and depressed patients
that really was eye-opening for me
Irina Esther les I already mentioned she
did the cholinesterase challenge with
the SPECT imaging Ron Duman has been a
long-term collaborator Ralph de Leon
brought a v2 and the shrnas to the lab
and then our funders we're not what's
interesting for me is that the nicotinic
agonist studies have never shown
rapid-acting the mecha melamine studies
that have been done and the one trial
with chantix with varenicline which is a
nicotinic partial agonist that's used
for smoking both of which showed
antidepressant effects in very small
groups had to be given chronically we're
given in concert with an SSRI just as I
showed you in the mouse if you put the
two together sub-threshold doses so in
patients who were on Prozac or something
like it but we're not responsive if you
added either varenicline which is this
nicotinic it's like cytosine or the pure
antagonist there seemed to be a better
response what I think would be most
interesting is to take a very selective
alpha for beta to antagonists which
would not hit the autonomic nervous
system and would be Mort well tolerated
the problem with MECA melamine is it
hits every nicotinic receptor and that's
the drug that was tried in the giant
trial that failed it makes people feel
terrible it backs them up quite
thoroughly because you need your
autonomic nervous system in order for
gut motility to occur and so you can
push the dose you couldn't actually get
up to lie
glia dose that was getting to
significant levels in the brain I think
a more selective agent might but again I
think that's unlikely to be developed
anytime soon yeah so this is actually
very interesting and important so if we
intervene pharmacologically all of the
things I showed you were one injection
of physostigmine and it does what I
showed you if we start to do chronic
infusion of fuzzy stigman we get as any
biochemist knows basically ten five to
ten fold up regulation of cholinesterase
levels and an incredible increase in
cholinesterase activity so these enzymes
are extremely homeostatic
pharmacologically in Alzheimer's
patients they may in fact first of all
it's a problem for Alzheimer's they may
have a lot more cholinesterase activity
because they've induced this homeostatic
upregulation that's not so good for
cognition but it may be okay for
depression because in fact they may be
either at normal levels because daesh's
maybe even less Astle choline signaling
than normal we do not see that
homeostasis with a knockdown
which is very interesting because it's
not a hundred percent knockdown are
efficient by structure is about
somewhere between fifty to sixty percent
now whether that means a hundred percent
down in sixty percent of the cells or
60% knockdown and all the cells that
expressed that we don't really know and
some point we can figure out by single
cell seek but for now what we know is
that doesn't change over time and I
don't know why there is no homeostasis
in the hippocampus as a result of the AV
just crazy so anyway all of that to say
that Alzheimer's patients who are
getting tatran or other cholinesterase
antagonists they get a little tiny bit
of boost from it but probably not very
much and likely because these are
biochemically extremely home aesthetic
enzymes
yeah well so there is a few patients in
which that's happened and they seem to
have much less fear certainly so fear
has always been the primary output
that's been investigated for basolateral
or firma in general if you look at
anxiety there seems to be a very good
correlation with activity in the
amygdala and an anxiety and so if you
look at for example Alex Honnold have
you heard of him Alex Honnold is a solo
climber he is the guy who goes with no
rope to the biggest rocks in Yosemite
and climbs them in two and a half hours
because he doesn't take time to put in
safety equipment if you image his
amygdala when he is climbing or when
he's were visualizing climbing because a
little hard to put an MRI machine on
yeah it's actually high when you're in
an MRI machine
he has exceedingly low amygdala activity
and that may be partly genetic it may be
actually training he may have taught his
amygdala to do that but if you look at
patients with depression you see at
least in some studies increased amygdala
activity in fMRI increased connectivity
with the amygdala in resting-state
connectivity studies and that may be
tracked that that may shift with whether
they're actively depressed or not and
it's certainly sex differences in that
so the connectivity of the immigrants
line is different in men and women
absolutely
yeah great question no nothing that we
can see so if we look at just
exploration in an open field they're
fine if we look at their wheat that's
kind of fine so I don't think there's a
big change in arousal I don't know why
but it doesn't at least it doesn't mean
to explain the differences in activity
in these stressful situations they're
not in the beaker of water
they're pretty normal looking yeah yes
absolutely yeah so that could be another
mechanism but in our experiments again
we used a v2 and as far as we know it
doesn't seem to infect astrocytes we've
looked I would not 100% rule out and a
glial phenotype but as far as we can
tell this is a neuronal phenotype alpha
7 is very interesting because it's been
shown in astrocytes to mediate or at
least be essential for calcium waves and
an effort astrocytes so so astrocyte
activity seems in in hippocampus and
specifically seems to really require
impact alpha 7 function it'd be pretty
cool if there was yet another role for
alpha 7 in hippocampus and these
behaviors that's mediated through
astrocytes we just didn't test it and
it's quite possible that that's one of
the reasons we don't have complete
behavioral effects maybe we're just
targeting neurons and maybe we should
have been targeting glia we'll do that
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]